can i revisit one thing you just said a
second ago
i i don't want to gloss over it because
i i mean i'm listening to you i'm being
educated beyond but you said that you
voted for biden and yeah i assume you
didn't do that lightly choice okay well
that's what i wanted to ask you is that
why do you feel like your back was
against the wall like if you didn't have
a choice to put it in putin in terms of
frankly and then what did you expect
from him and what did you know what do
you what grade would you i guess give
him now i you know i'm a sucker for
believing i'm an optimist and i believe
that he reached a certain age
a 78 then he's a little more mature and
that he sees the bigger picture
and in this case ukraine he is cr he's
making a big mistake
a big mistake he's oh he thinks he's off
the hook he's he looks like the good guy
now with all this anti-russian thing but
when we get to a deeper place which is
where it's going to go
and this thing gets harder and harder
for americans
and they might be they were not passed
any war yet the war could expand
that certainly zolensky would like the
war to expand because he would sacrifice
the world in order to save ukraine he
doesn't care about us he doesn't care
about he sees his whole thing as a
crusade as a jihad
biden has given him the go ahead
to do this
biden is the one who should be calming
this situation down he should be
speaking to putin speaking to zolansky
calming it down being a statesman
instead of a ideologue
this is a time for
a
a kennedy this is a time that's what
kennedy did with khrushchev this is a
time for statesmen
statesmen you know like charles de
gaulle somebody who really has a picture
of the world i i was hoping macro of
france could have some effect
but
you can't get through the ukrainian u.s
connection that's the problem but beyond
ukraine i mean what's happening there's
no beyond ukraine right now because it's
stuck there there's a disconnect the
americans see russia as a evil
and
they don't understand and the russian
position which is crazy why can't a
statesman understand
what russia is thinking
putin is fighting for his life
you can get rid of him but whoever takes
his place will probably be tougher
because they know that they're up
against it okay
what let them give up let's say okay
give up so what do you do if you want to
give up
all right then you put your put your put
nato in into ukraine put put missiles
into ukraine fine you can put them right
on our border we'll take all the
refugees you can give us and uh there'll
be another confrontation when you make
your next move
and one of the things you often hear
though is well this would be different
under trump
nothing happened with ukraine and russia
under trump that's not true that's not
true at all trump on the contrary is a
very strange guy he was making sounds
about putin when he was came in and i
was hoping that there'd be some dayton
but as as he got more and more pressure
for his uh russiagate which was a joke
but it was a serious serious accusation
that was of course political too putting
pressure on trump not allowing him to
get anything done
with this pressure from russiagate for
what two years that was insane that he
was a russian agent all that stuff
no one i mean if you were thinking it's
it was so ridiculous and i asked putin
about that too and
putin practically laughed it was he
knows that it's not possible but they
they pictured trump as a tool as a
manchurian candidate or something as a
result
he became very anti-russian too in the
sense that he was passed every single
sanction against russia that was asked
put onto him by congress
check his record on russia he did
everything they wanted
and then recently i i saw yesterday or
two days ago one of his comments which
was insane he said
he would he would he would he's not a
coward like uh like bi and something
like biden is a weakling something like
that implying that he would be much
tougher which means what war nuclear war
to my mind last thing before we wrap up
here um
what what so you said that the right
thing to do right now for biden is to be
a statesman um
to be a statesman right thing for him to
do right now is to be a statesman reach
out to putin have a meeting with him sit
down have that conversation well he also
has to take the pr he has to deal with
ukrainian and he has to deal with a
neo-nazi issue he's got to deal with the
ukraine administration the way
that country is run
there
i think if you obviously if we could
reach a deal where we could they could
split east and west it would it would
but it's very hard to do that
yeah that's not going to be easy to do
though i don't think that's the
direction it's going to go you saw they
made him an offer and zielinski turned
it down
but he promised them that he's going to
cool off the negotiation with nato and
he's kind of backing out from getting
closer to nato it seems like uh
you know who who is who's putin most uh
annoyed and upset with for him to get to
this point is he seen it from your
opinion as being opportunistic saying
i'd rather do it under biden because of
how they handled afghanistan and the
taliban got what they wanted rather than
trump is it more purely he's just being
uh opportunistic or did somebody do
something with a proxy nato biden u.s
somebody pissed him off to say this is
the time to go he didn't get pissed off
no he just
he doesn't get pissed off what struck me
about him over these years that i met
him was how cool he was how rational
he's a he's a chess player
he does he looks at politics as without
emotion and that's i think one of his
powerful
you know you you talk to you talk about
him as if he's some
villain in the west but the truth is if
you go to africa and you go to the
middle east and parts of asia you'd be
surprised that he's admired as one of
the best statesmen of this era
but unfortunately we've put him in this
it's a disconnect between america and
partly because of our propaganda it's
very powerful i'm surprised by the eu's
tough
i mean basically you understand biden
made this move using ukraine but it
helps him with eu and nato it makes
their
dependence on the united states even
tighter
so and he was worried about losing their
control of the eu sector because they're
economically much more involved with
russia and china than than we would like
what what's what's the worst thing last
question what's the worst thing putin is
capable of doing the worst thing
and yes the worst thing he's capable of
doing if we keep playing the strategy
there's no way there's no hope down that
road okay so if we put more pressure and
more pressure which is what happened
recently he's going to fight back
and
will he blow up the world
why god i
what does he i mean
is he supposed to sacrifice russia to
the world perhaps that's the ultimate
question right are you willing to become
leave office uh be whatever be shamed
would you be willing to let russia
become
open to nato or whatever you wanted you
know
something like that but that would be a
complete capitulation wouldn't it
and that would be the end of the uh the
russians are very proud people uh the
ones that i saw they're very proud
their country is
i said he's a son of russia he's not a
communist he's not an evil bench he's a
son of russia he's very lower class came
from a poor family parents were in the
war i mean the whole story it's just
and 90's he's not a kgb agent that's
another ridiculous thing you hear that
george bush was in the cia but we don't
say he was a cia agent but that's an
american denigration as if he's still
thinking like his kgb agent out of james
bond and he wants to he wants to kill
people it's it's childish
he's a russian patriot
and if we see him that way
you can start to deal with them
but there's so russia phobia in this
country it's as i say going back to 1970
18.
i wish
you need a statesman you need american
statesmen who's the last one kennedy
do we have a current one right now
gorbachev is still alive i wish he'd
come out of he's old i met him a few
times
i like gorbachev but i don't think the
american side would even
even deal with them i mean they wouldn't
understand what his contribution has
been to the world i thought 1986 was
going to be a new era when he came in
who was gorbachev he came out of nowhere
to me
and it was a beautiful moment in time
have you thought about reaching out to
him and having an interview with him or
no
i mean he knows what's going on i mean
would the americans accept him as as an
arbitrator here can you pull up a
picture of him right now mikhail
gorbachev if you had if you had george
schultz and gorbachev and if george was
still alive they would be the perfect
older men is there anyone in america
right now that is the perfect statesman
that could could maybe step up
he's not going to be biden and according
to you
yeah maybe obama
you think obama maybe
although he's
you know he's so he's so aware of the
popular will
that he would he would he bucket so if
you enjoyed this little segment from the
podcast click over here to watch the
entire podcast and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
take care everybody
[Music]